en todos los vídeos que hemos hecho
hasta ahora de integración doble los
límites de integración han sido números
fijos en este vídeo quiero ver qué pasa
cuando la región de integración no es un
rectángulo y entonces los límites son
variables la superficie que usaremos
será la misma de los primeros vídeos
ahora no lo voy a dibujar muy bien
simplemente voy a dibujar una
aproximación la superficie era bueno
antes de escribirla el punto no va a ser
enseñarte a cómo integrar sino cómo
identificar la región integración para
ser sincero esto suele ser la parte más
difícil en este tipo de problemas una
vez que encontremos los límites de
integración resolver la integral no es
tan difícil entonces tenemos la
superficie zeta igual a xy cuadrada voy
a dibujar mis ejes a ver lo voy a poner
por acá el eje x
por acá está el eje z y por acá está el
eje y
saleh déjame marcarlos esté aquí es x
este de aquí ese este de aquí es z y
bueno ya vimos cómo es esta superficie
hace algunos vídeos sacamos el programa
para graficar la vimos la rotamos y todo
en esta ocasión no la volvería a dibujar
sino que simplemente haría una
superficie muy estándar y abstracta
recordamos que el punto es encontrar los
límites de integración antes incluso de
dibujar la superficie voy a dibujar la
región de integración la primera vez que
resolvimos el problema teníamos que aquí
se va de 0 a 2 y ahí va de 0 a 1 y con
eso pudimos encontrar el volumen dentro
de esta región restringida ahora haremos
algo distinto supongamos que x va de 0 a
1 deja lo pongo aquí x va de 0 a 1 hasta
ahora todo va igual pero la aie lo que
va a pasar con lay es que va va a
moverse dependiendo de la x a ver déjame
marcar por aquí una línea en x igual a 1
y lo que pasa con la aie no es de una
fija
bueno creo que es más fácil dibujarlo a
ver lo que vamos a tener aquí en el
plano aquí se va a ser una curva va esta
curva que nos queda la podemos pensar de
dos formas una de las formas es que ya
es una función de x igual a x cuadrada o
bien podríamos poner x igual a raíz de y
poniendo a x como una función de ya no
tenemos que preocuparnos por el signo
pues estamos en el primer cuadrante
entonces esta es el área sobre la cual
queremos calcular el volumen déjame
acabar de sombrear la a ver ahí va
está ya quedando más marcada para para
realmente entender qué es lo que nos
importa entonces esta va a ser el área
sobre la cual queremos encontrar el
volumen este va a ser en nuestra región
de integración este punto de aquí es el
11 si le ponemos ya igual a 1 nos queda
x es igual a 1 entonces aquí nos va a
quedar igual a 1 voy a poner una línea
punteada hacia allá y no voy a dibujar
la superficie solo te voy a dar una idea
de más o menos cómodo como como que
estilo de cosas se va a ver supongamos
que la parte superior de la superficie
se ve más o menos algo de este estilo
esto es una línea paralela al eje z aquí
también voy a dibujar una línea paralela
al eje zeta
ipad
y ahora esta curva cuando suba
perpendicularmente va a actuar como una
pared que va a limitar la superficie
déjalo dibujo para que veas a qué me
refiero esa pared la voy a sombrear un
poco para que veas espero que le puedas
ver un poco la perspectiva estoy
haciendo mi mejor esfuerzo para que esto
quede super padre entonces a ver ipad
ya sé vamos a pintarlo con un color un
poco más oscuro para que para que se
entienda cómo va el dibujo
y ahora déjame déjame dibujarla la
región por aquí ahora bueno esta
superficie no necesariamente va a ser
plana podría ser un poquito curva
depende de cómo sea la superficie
esta superficie de aquí se llama xy
cuadrada ahora si quisiéramos encontrar
el volumen debajo de esta superficie y
sobre el plano xy cómo le vamos a hacer
para hacer eso bueno lo que vamos a
hacer es pensar el problema con la
intuición que vimos en el vídeo pasado
esencialmente que vamos a tomar aquí
abajo un pequeño cuadrado una pequeña
región que le vamos a llamar de a
esa de ahí tiene dos lados tiene a ver
voy a marcarlo con un color un poco más
fuerte tiene un lado que me de fx y
tiene un lado que me desde ya y ahora lo
que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar esa
área por fx
es decir por zeta
finalmente tenemos que sumar todas esas
cosas y eso nos va a dar el volumen
debajo de la superficie tenemos que
decidirnos y primero fijar x o primero
fijar ya debes estar seguro de que
entiendes la intuición déjame déjame
déjame pasar por acá en el plano aquí
para entender un poco mejor la región de
integración eso es lo más importante del
problema verdad una vez que encontramos
la los límites de integración ya va a
ser fácil hacer bueno evaluar la
integral
entonces la curva es igual a equis
cuadrada entonces viene más o menos por
aquí aquí es 1 llegó a la 1 aquí tenemos
el eje x aquí esto de aquí le vamos a
poner x igual a 1 bueno déjame respetar
esta x más bien este aquí es el punto 1
en el eje x
entonces lo que queremos determinar es
como encontrar la suma de todos estas
todas estas regiones que están sobre los
pequeños rectángulos
entonces vamos a dibujar lo vamos a
pasar el pequeño rectángulo a nuestro
dibujo del plano xy eso francamente es
la parte más difícil entonces va nuestro
rectángulo va a quedar una cosa de este
estilo
lo voy a dibujar aquí con color morado y
entonces esta área estaría aquí es lo
mismo que este rectángulo su base es de
x su altura es de g
y entonces ahora vamos a imaginarnos
vamos a imaginarnos bueno lo que podemos
hacer es imaginarnos que esta superficie
es lo mismo que si viéramos nuestro
sólido en 3-d desde arriba pero
supongamos que queremos tomar la
integral con respecto a x primero
entonces lo que queremos hacer es sumar
si queremos encontrar el volumen sobre
esta columna
hay que multiplicar esta área de equipo
la altura entonces vamos a encontrar el
volumen de una columna a la altura de la
columna fíjate ahí estoy dibujando la
columna entonces la altura es xy
cuadrada y eso lo voy a multiplicar por
de x b
esta expresión nos da el volumen de una
sola de las columnas pero ahora tenemos
que recorrer en alguna dirección
supongamos que primero queremos recorrer
en el eje x más o menos así es decir
tenemos varias columnas por aquí por
aquí y lo que queremos hacer es
determinar el volumen sobre sobre estos
rectángulos cuál va a ser nuestro límite
inferior de integración a ver esa es la
pregunta interesante fíjate vamos a
dejar una constante y entonces sí nos
vamos yendo hacia la izquierda vamos a
chocar contra la curva eso nos debería
de dar la intuición de cuál es el límite
inferior de x como esta curva es la
curva igual a equis cuadrada también la
podemos pensar como x es igual a raíz de
y entonces
para integrar con respecto a x si
tenemos una eficaz tenemos que empezar
tenemos que empezar en la curva es decir
tenemos que empezar en la raíz cuadrada
de y vamos a ponerle aquí x igual la
raíz cuadrada de ella
esto es interesante verdad a lo mejor es
la primera vez que ves una variable en
un límite de integración pero tiene todo
el sentido estamos sumando vamos con el
límite superior el límite superior está
fácil x es igual a 1 pero lo que estamos
haciendo es sumar desde x es igual a
raíz de iu porque estamos chocando aquí
con la curva y ya nada más tenemos que
recorrer hacia la derecha
muy bien una vez que encontramos el
volumen que está sobre este rectángulo
una vez que encontramos el volumen que
está sobre ese rectángulo queremos
integrar ahora con respecto al es decir
queremos queremos ir sumando todos estos
rectángulos acuérdate que hay volúmenes
sobre estos rectángulos simplemente
estamos dando la representación plana de
la región de integración entonces va ahí
está ahora lo estoy poniendo en 3-d para
que ve para que entendamos un poco mejor
qué pasa pero ahora si queremos
encontrar el volumen de toda la región
de todo el sólido que está debajo de la
superficie tenemos que integrar ahora en
el eje de la jr aquí tenemos un de yebra
mide xy mide ya se parecen mucho pero
pero hay que aprender a distinguirlos
entonces cuál es el límite inferior para
allí
pues va ese ya está más fácil fíjate qué
valores puede tomar y así cuáles son
todos los valores que puede tomar pues
ya puede empezar desde ya es igual a
cero
y a dónde tiene que llegar pues puede
llegar a ser uno listo déjame reescribir
esa integral aquí abajo para poder
integrarla vamos a ponerle x igual a
raíz de y en el límite inferior x igual
a 1 en el límite superior x de cuadrada
de x belle y luego aquí afuera hay que
integrar desde cero hasta allí igual a 1
bueno vamos a dejarle hasta aquí en el
siguiente vídeo evaluaremos la integral
y experimentaremos cambiando el orden de
integración